Und?
Ja, das ist mein Name.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarztätich.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Aufnahmegeschichte führen.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuelle Beschwerde kommen,
soll ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Was irgendetwas unklar ist, fragen Sie gerne nach.
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Frieda Feuerstein.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Ja, Frieda Feuerstein.
Darf ich Ihre Vorname stabilen?
Ja, F-R-I-E-D-A, Frieda.
Ja, und der Nachname Feuerstein, F-E-U-E-R-S-T-E-I-N.
Frieda.
Sie sprechen richtig aus, Frau Frieda.
Ja, sprechen Sie richtig aus.
Gut.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Frieda?
Ich bin 33.
33 Jahre.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 3. Mai 1992.
1992.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie, aktuelle wissen Sie?
60 Kilogramm.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Frau Feuerstein?
Ich bin seit ungefähr 3 Wochen sehr müde.
Ich bin schnell erschöpft.
Ich habe auch Luftnot beim Treppensteigen.
Ich habe auch Fieber bekommen.
Ich habe 5 Tage Fieber bekommen, bis 39 Grad.
29 Grad.
Wann sind Sie gemessen?
1 oder 2 oder heute oder gestern?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 5 Tagen Fieber.
Ich habe immer gemessen morgens und abends.
Immer 39.
Ja, morgens.
Hat vielleicht etwas weniger.
38, 35, 38, 6.
Aber abends 39.
abends 39. 39, ja. Sie haben Müdigkeit, Schlaf, Schlepfing und Luftnot seit drei Wochen, aber Sie haben Fieber nur seit fünf Tagen.
Ungefähr, ja. Ja, ungefähr. Okay.
Herr Frau Feuerstein, husten Sie?
Nein, husten habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in den Körperteilen?
Ja, ich habe ein bisschen Halsschmerzen.
Beim Schlucken tut es mir weh und ich habe so bemerkt, dass mein Hals etwas mehr dicker geworden ist, angeschwollend, wie an der Seite so.
Das ist so an der Seite.
Okay.
Ich möchte jetzt auch gar nicht mehr irgendwie einen Rollkragen Pullover tragen, das ist mir zu eng.
Ja.
Seitlich dicker geworden, Sie haben bemerkt.
Frau Feuerstein, haben Sie Ihre Achselhöhe oder andere Körper eine Lämpfnoten bemerkt oder eine Schwelligung bemerkt, leistensbereit oder Achselhöhe?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt, ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Ich habe allerdings auch nicht gefühlt, aber ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Gut, das ist sehr gut.
Frau Feuerstein, haben Sie Nachtschweiß oder Schütterfrost?
Ja, Nachtschweiß.
Sondern Nachtschweiß, sollen Sie Ihre Kleidung umziehen?
Ja, ich muss manchmal jetzt nachts mein Hemd wechseln, das ist dann durchgeschwitzt.
Frau Feuerstein, haben Sie Ihre Zahnfleisch, während die Pützen, Blutung oder andere Probleme oder in irgendwelchen Teile eine Blauflecken?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Die Leiden, Müdeschlafligkeit und Fieber, Schütterfrost, Entschuldige, haben Sie Schwindeln?
Nein, Schwindel habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Nein, Erbrechen habe ich nicht, aber mein Appetit ist jetzt, seitdem ich das Fieber habe, mein Appetit ist nicht mehr so gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungefähr letzte sechs Monate abgenommen?
Also ich habe vier Kilo abgenommen innerhalb der letzten vier Wochen.
Ja, letzte vier Wochen.
Frau Feuerstein, haben Sie Schuttelgang oder Wasserlassensprobleme?
Wasserlassensysteme, in Ordnung.
Schuttelgang habe ich in letzter Zeit manchmal etwas Durchfall, aber das ist jetzt nicht immer, aber manchmal.
Haben Sie etwas Ihrer Hautblässe bemerkt?
Hautblässe, nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Gut.
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Ja, haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Seitdem ich das Fieber habe, seit den letzten fünf Tagen, habe ich nicht so gut geschlafen.
Sonst kann ich eigentlich ganz gut schlafen, weil ich auch so erschöpft bin, so schnell müde bin.
Frau Feuerstein, nehmen Sie gegen diese Fieber eine Medikamente oder andere Beschwerde eine Medikamente ein?
Nein, in den letzten Tagen habe ich nichts Besonderes eingenommen, außer meine normalen Medikamente, die ich sonst nehme.
Sonst habe ich nichts gegen Fieber eingenommen.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerde erst einmal?
Ja.
Haben Sie diese Beschwerde in der letzten 50.000 Euro gehabt?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich würde gerne ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer kranken Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie andauerhafte oder chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr 18 Jahren Milchzucker und Verträglichkeit.
Seitdem ich das weiß, ernähre ich mich etwas anders.
Es gibt ja inzwischen auch Nahrungsmittel, die Milchzucker frei sind.
Das geht ganz gut. Die Beschwerden sind deutlich besser geworden.
Ich hatte viel Bauchschmerzen, viel Blähungen und Durchfall, aber das ist schon lange her.
Das ist seit 18 Jahren bekannt.
Dann habe ich seit der Pubertät, das ist so jetzt auch ungefähr die Zeit, 18, 19 Jahre habe ich eine chronische Schilddrüsenentzündung.
Im Anfang war eine Unterfunktion dabei und ich nehme da eine Tablette täglich ein, damit die Schilddrüsenfunktion wieder in Ordnung ist.
Erinnerle Sie die Tablettenamen?
Ja, die Tablette heißt Euthyrox.
Wie viel Milligramm erinnerle Sie daran?
50. Euthyrox 50 und dann nehme ich eine Tablette morgens.
Leiden Sie andere chronische Erkrankungen an?
Nein.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kleinkind hatte ich einen Wasserkopf.
Da wurde eine Drennage gelegt vom Kopf in den Bauchraum.
Unter der Bauchdecke durch in den Bauchraum.
Somit konnte das Wasser, das im Kopf zu viel war, im Gehirn abgeleitet werden.
Es ist sehr früh operiert und entdeckt worden.
Dann habe ich mit 10 Jahren im Alter von 10 Jahren eine Blindaboperation.
Im Alter von 12 Jahren hatte ich Mandeloperation.
Mandeloperation?
Sind alle Operationen komplikationslos veraufguckt?
Ja.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie nehmen regelmäßig Euthyrox 50 Milligramm ein.
Nehmen Sie bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig andere Medikamente ein?
Nein, sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie leiden an Milch, Zucker und Verträglichkeit.
Sind bei Ihnen andere Allergien bekannt?
Ich habe eine Allergie auf Nickel.
Ich hatte einen Gürtel und die Gürtelschnalle hatte ich einen Ausschlag am Bauch.
Ich hatte einen Armband aus Nickel.
Das machte Ausschlag und dann hat man mich getestet.
Ich habe eine Nickel Allergie.
Nickel Allergie?
Als Ausschlagreagier.
Aber seitdem ich das weiß, nehme ich keine Metallstücke aus Nickel bestehen.
Keine Gürtelschnalle oder kein Schmiel.
Frau Feuerstein, ich könnte Sie mir bitte sagen, ob Sie rauchen?
Ich rauche nicht, ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ich graue Ihnen. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Selten, vielleicht mal ein Glas Wein pro Woche, am Wochenende mal ein Glas Wein zum Essen.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine rutinere Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Frau Feuerstein, besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Frau Arzt?
Ja, ich gehe regelmäßig zur Frauenärztin, da war ich zuletzt glaube ich,
und war das im Januar, das war bei alles in Ordnung.
Alles Ordnung. Ihre Regelpolitik ist regelmäßig, alles ist ordnung.
Letzte Periode war so vor 2,5 Wochen, 3 Wochen.
Sind Sie alle Kinderkrankheiten und Corona vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also da schaut immer meine Hausärzte nach, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Ich hatte jetzt auch noch zusätzliche Impfungen bekommen, weil ich in Thailand war und kam Boca.
Und da habe ich dann auch noch andere Impfungen bekommen.
Gut.
Ja, ich würde wissen, ob Ihre Eltern noch leben.
Ja, der Vater ist 66 Jahre alt, der hat seit 2 Jahren chronische Leukämie,
und er hatte seit ungefähr 10 Jahren hohen Blutdruck.
10 Jahre?
Und die Mutter, die ist aus 60 Jahre alt, die hat seit ungefähr 5 Jahren eine chronische Bauchspeicheldrüsenentzündung.
Man weiß aber nicht genau die Ursache, sie trinkt kaum Alkohol oder gar kein Alkohol und hat wenig Alkohol getrunken,
aber sie hat eine chronische Bauchspeicheldrüsenentzündung und das beeinträchtigt sie schon, also Lebensqualität.
Okay, verstehe ich. Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder, der ist 34 Jahre alt, der hatte, als er 18 Jahre alt war,
wurde bei ihm eine Lymphogranulomatose festgestellt.
Entschuldige, ich habe nicht gut gehört, Lenfo?
Eine Lymphogranulomatose, das ist aber behandelt worden und er gilt als Gehalt.
Gut. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin nicht verheiratet, ich habe auch keine Kinder.
Wo wohnen Sie oder lieben Sie allein?
Ja, ich habe eine Wohnung, in der zweiten Etage eine Mietwohnung.
Allein leben?
Ich wohne alleine, habe aber einen Partner, der hat aber eine eigene Wohnung.
Okay. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Lehrerin.
Ja, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen für mich gestellt.
Wollen Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich mache mir Sorgen, was das sein kann.
Was habe ich noch nie gehabt, auch so hohes Fieber,
so lange und dann auch diese Müdigkeit und diese Schlappheit?
Ja, das ist zu früh, um eine Diagnose zu sagen.
Ich habe eine Vermutung, vielleicht haben Sie Probleme mit Weißblut
oder Lymphsystemprobleme, aber vor einer Diagnose
sollen wir ein paar Untersuchungen durchführen,
zuerst körperliche Untersuchungen, danach Laboruntersuchungen durchführen.
Okay.
Vielleicht brauchen wir bildgebende Verfahren,
nachdem alle Ergebnisse abgeschlossen sind, können wir
die Ursache Ihrer Beschwerden widerschübbrechen.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Die Sorgen sind bei uns bleiben, weiter Untersuchungen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit, sich vorzubereiten.
Begriffe der Patientin in Fachsprache zu übersetzen.
Und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen haben vielleicht noch ergänzende Fragen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja?
Leidung Sie besonders in der Lesterzeit Stress?
Nein, nicht mehr Stress als sonst.
Der Beruf der Lehrerin ist sehr stressig,
aber in letzter Zeit ist nichts Besonderes dazugekommen.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Normalerweise treibe ich Sport.
Ich gehe normalerweise so zweimal in der Woche joggen
und mache Yoga, aber seit drei Wochen,
seitdem ich mich so müde und schlapp fühle,
habe ich keinen Sport gemacht.
Ja, ich verstehe. Dankeschön.
Ja, da unten ist eine Frage im Chat.
Ich lese die gerade.
Die Patientin hat die Frage schon eigentlich beantwortet.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, dass sie vor vier Monaten in Thailand
und Cambodia war.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt das.
Ja, weil die Frage wurde gerade im Chat gestellt.
Aber vor und nach haben Sie kontrolliert und Ihre Impfung?
Die Impfung, ich war bei der Hausärztin und beim Tropenmediziner
und habe zum Beispiel auch eine Impfung bekommen,
japanische Encephalitis, Hepatitis.
Ich habe auch Malaria-Profilaxe gemacht.
Ich hatte dort allerdings einen Magendamenfekt
und habe die Malaria-Profilaxe für zwei Tage ausgesetzt,
weil da konnte ich nichts zu mir nehmen.
Gelenksperzen habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie gegen Covid geimpft?
Covid, ja.
Ja, ich bin zwischen, glaube ich, fünfmal geimpft gegen Covid.
Ich möchte eine neue Patientin vorstellen, Darfi.
Bitte schön.
Ja, Frau Frieder-Feuerstein.
Ist eine 33-jährige Patientin zeitlich, örtlich und persönlich orientiert
und leicht untergewichtigen Ernährungszustand
und in beschwerdenbedingten, deutlich reduziertem Allgemeinzustand.
Die Patientin stellte sich heute auf unserer Station
mit seinen drei Woku-Bestehenden,
die Probedienten, Fatigue, Abgeschlagenheit und Belastungdispnö
vor, die von Plexi begleitet seien.
Die haben ihre Körpertemperatur selbst gemessen
gestern und vorgestern zweimal täglich
und sie haben ihre Körpertemperatur 39 Grad gefunden.
Wo wurde die Temperatur gemessen? Wissen Sie das?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Ja, oral im Mund.
Es bestehen seit fünf Tagen febrile Temperaturen
bis 39 Grad oral gemessen.
Darüber hinaus berichtete sie, dass sie unter Gewichtverlust leiden.
Sie haben innerhalb vier Wochen
von vier Kilo abgenommen.
Abgeschlagen davon klagte sie über Nausea und Nachschweiß.
Nachschweiß.
Aus dem klagte sie über Halsschwellung, Halsödeme.
Ich denke, das ist eine Lämpfergrösserung.
Das wäre jetzt schon eine Diagnose.
Die Patientin klagt über servikale Schwellungen.
Das ist offen.
Damit haben wir uns noch nicht festgelegt.
Was worüber klagt die Patientin noch?
Hat die Patientin Schmerzen?
Die Patientin ist leider unter Halsschmerzen,
insbesondere während der Schlucken.
Die Patientin leidet auch unter Dysphagie.
Die Schwellungen verbunden mit einer gewissen Dysphagie.
Was kannst du noch berechnen?
Die vegetifische Anamnesis ist bis auf oben genannte Symptome.
Ich werde in Somni bedingt.
In Appetit.
Unaufwändig.
Anvor Erkrankungen.
Entschuldige.
Leider Sie seit 18 Jahren chronische Hypotroidism.
Ja, chronische Hypotroidism.
Oder hypothyriose.
Das heißt, eine chronische Schilddrüsenentzündung.
Unter Funktion Hypotroidism.
Man kann wahrscheinlich sagen, es ist wahrscheinlich,
was häufig ist, eine Autoimmuntyrioeditis.
Das ist wahrscheinlich Typ Hashimoto.
Hashimoto.
Die Medikamentös mit Ötropst, 15 Milligramm,
einmal täglich behandelt worden sei.
Ja, wird immer noch behandelt.
Was hat sie noch für chronische Erkrankungen?
Leider Sie Leider anhidrocephalie.
Sie hat noch eine andere chronische Erkrankung.
Sie hat eine Tyrioeditis.
Sie leiden unter, Sie leiden an Laktosintoleranz.
Seit 18 Jahren.
Und diese Laktoseintoleranz ist durch die Äthe deutlich besser geworden.
Ja, und außerdem Leider anhidrocephalie,
Entschuldige Leider, Sie haben hidrocephalie in Kindheit gelitten.
Und deswegen wurde bei ihr eine Operation durchgeführt.
Kennen Sie den Begriff der Schandoperation?
Ja, eine Schandoperation durchgeführt worden.
Als Kleinkind.
Im Kleinkind alter erfolgte eine Schandopie wegen Hydrocephalie.
Geben Sie eine Operation?
Ja, im Alter von 10 Jahren wurde sie wegen Epandysitis
eine Ependectomy durchgeführt worden.
Sagen Sie einfach, im Alter von 10 Jahren ist sie appendectomiert worden?
Ja, außerdem sei sie im Alter von 12 Jahre
Tonselectomy durchgeführt worden.
Okay, sehr gut.
Sie leide auf die Frage nach Allergien,
gab die Patienten auf eine Nickelallergie,
mit Exantem zu reagieren.
Ja, mit Exem, oder ja, mit Exem.
Okay, gut.
Um Rauchverhalten erklärte die Patienten, sie sei nicht Raucherin.
Genau, die Patientin ist nicht Raucherin.
Sie trink ein Glas Wein pro Woche, Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Sie besuche regelmäßig ihre Frau Arzt
und sie haben keine Frau Probleme.
Die letzte Kontrolle war dieses Jahr in Januar.
Okay.
Und die letzte Regelblutung war vor drei Wochen.
Okay, gut.
Und die Familienanamnese ergab,
eine chronische Löke bei dem Vater.
Und der Vater der Patientin,
leider auch Arterielle Hypertonie seit zehn Jahren.
Okay.
Die Mutter der Patientin, leider chronische Pankratie,
seit fünf Jahren.
Ja.
Aber es gibt keine besondere Auslöse.
Der Bruder der Patientin leider,
Entschuldige, habe mit 18 Jahre
Lenfburg Granlamatov gelitten.
Aber es sei gut behandelt worden.
Wie alt ist der Bruder jetzt?
34.
Okay, gut.
Ja, haben wir noch etwas vergessen?
Ja, sie sei ledig und keine Kinder.
Sie wohnen allein und sie sind Lehrerin.
Ja, okay.
Noch, es fehlt doch eine anamnästische Angabe
aus der jüngeren Zeit, aus den letzten Monaten.
Können Sie sich erinnern?
Denken Sie an die Reise der Patientin.
Ja, die Reise der Patientin,
zwei Thailand und Cambodia gereist.
Und wann waren sie?
Vor einem Monat.
Vor vier Monaten.
Vor vier Monaten ja, Thailand und Cambodia gereist.
Hat die Patientin alle notwendigen Impfungen
und Profi längst angemacht?
Ja.
Okay, gut.
Ja, was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die allen Stichnangaben deuten am ersten auf eine Lymphoma hin.
Ja, Lymphoma und Lymphoma.
Ja, dafür ist von allem nach Schweiß-Fatüky
Abgeschlagenheit, FIBA, vielleicht.
Und außerdem unterstützt die Risikofaktoren
ihre Familienvorgeschichte,
ihre Vater, leider an chronische Leukemia
und ihre Brüder auch leider an Lymphogranamiteuse.
Okay, gut. Kann ich nachvollziehen.
Was könnte denn differentialdiagnostisch sein?
Alkdifferentielle Diagnose kommen,
die Folgen der Erkrankung in Betah, Infektiöse, Mononucleosis
und Leukemia.
Ja.
Und vielheit auch Hypotroidi, oder Infekts.
Ja, ich habe keine alternative Diagnose.
Gut, okay. Aber ich war schon, also ja, einverstanden.
Eventuell kommt noch eine Malaria infrage.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, die Malaria.
Ich habe eine Malaria-Prophylaxe betrieben,
aber an zwei Tagen hat sie die Malaria-Prophylaxe
in Karbocce ausgesetzt, weil sie wohl eine Gastroenteritis hatte.
Ja.
Und eine Malaria kann auch durchaus vielfältige Gesichter haben,
Symptome machen.
Ja.
Er leichte Diarröhe, sie hat das Fieber und sie war vor vier Monaten
zumindest in Malaria-Gebiet.
Und das muss man zumindest, würde ich das in die Differenzialdiagnostik
einbeziehen, dass zumindest sie auf Malaria getestet wird.
Ja.
Okay.
Dass man das nicht übersieht.
Aber in erster Linie muss man wahrscheinlich an ein Lymphom denken
bei der Patientin, infektiöse Mononucleose,
bin ich sehr dafür.
Ich hatte die selber mal als Student.
Da ging es mir ganz schlecht.
Und hatte auch lange Fieber und Schluckstörungen und was
und Schwellungen am Hals.
Die Milz war groß.
Also das gibt es auch.
Aber ich würde in erster Linie wahrscheinlich an ein Lymphom denken.
Aber bitte die Malaria nicht vergessen.
Okay.
Verstehe ich.
Das könnte, das ist eine schnelle Diagnostik und man kann sie
dann natürlich auch gezielt therapieren,
weil da zählt auch natürlich dann auch möglichst jeder Tag.
Gut, aber ich war sehr einverstanden damit.
Ich war sehr einverstanden mit der Art ihrer Anamnese-Erhebung.
Das fand ich sehr gut.
Sie haben auch die allermeisten Fachbegriffe sehr gut gebracht,
die erforderlich waren.
Und ich konnte sie gut verstehen.
Und auch mit der Differenzialdiagnose war ich zufrieden.
Es geht ja nicht darum, dass es eine fachliche Prüfung jetzt ist,
sondern es geht um die Sprache.
Aber sie denke ich waren auf dem richtigen diagnostischen Weg.
Das ist gut.
Sie haben mir glaube ich schon mal gesagt,
wann Sie Ihre Prüfung haben.
Ja, 5. Juli.
Ja, okay.
Sind Sie inzwischen schon sehr gut vorbereitet?
Vielen Dank.
Gut.
Unser nächster Termin.